[Applause]
so I'm very excited to be here today
partly because I actually started
Burchard omics when I was a student so I
was originally a grad student at UCLA
when I first started becoming interested
in the drug discovery process and it was
in that moment I realized how broken
drug discovery is right now it's still
largely a guessing game
but we're in this really unique moment
of time right now where advances in
genomics and machine learning are really
poising us to rethink the way we do drug
discovery and take a lot of the
guesswork out of drug discovery and so I
started virtually with a vision of
creating a scaleable drug discovery
engine that could be repeated not just
for one disease but across in many
different diseases and eventually apply
to even larger human conditions such as
aging disease prevention and addiction
so I want to start out with kind of why
I went into the field in the first place
which is for the patients and at Verge
our first disease area that we focused
in is an ALS so ALS is a rapidly
degenerating disorder in which patients
progressively become paralyzed losing
their ability to walk to eat and
eventually to freeze and unfortunately
because most of these patients die
within three years and under our current
drug discovery system it takes over 15
years just to find a single new drug
most of these patients won't get the
drugs that they need average we've been
able to use artificial intelligence to
identify over a dozen promising drug
candidates they're showing effect in our
preclinical models they're showing
effect in mice that we've engineered
with ALS in them so I'm about to show
you a video of three mice that have ALS
and they're at the kind of initial early
stages of ALS where they're starting to
lose their ability to walk and their
muscles are starting to waste and so you
can see that these muscles of these mice
already losing their ability to walk and
have a hard time staying
this rotating wheel but when we give
these very same ALS mice injections of a
drug discovered entirely by our platform
they recover their ability to walk and
stay on this rotating wheel and what's
so exciting about this drug is that it's
actually just one of many drugs that
we've identified showing promising
effects in the lab but also one of many
diseases that we're currently pursuing
and that's really what is so exciting to
me about this platform is the potential
to find drugs not just for one disease
but to eventually scale across many
different diseases and I've Virge were
building an engine really with the
vision of creating and helping enable a
world in which cures exist for every
single human disease out there without
an available treatment but first I want
to start by taking you through kind of
my personal story and where it all began
because if you had asked me five years
ago or told me five years ago that you
would be a CEO of a biotech company I
probably would have laughed I would be
like never in a million years so I was
born in the DC area and here are my
parents they're immigrants from China
this is a picture of me from what my
friends called the Bruce Lee era because
apparently he looked like Bruce Lee with
an awesome haircut in monochromatic
jumpsuit but really it was a unique
moment like shortly thereafter around
middle school when I started realizing
what death was kind of dark and morbid
but I couldn't stop thinking about it
and I was like you know what do I want
to be thinking in the very last moment
on my deathbed what does the last
thought I want to have and I realized
that what I wanted to be thinking was
that I have made the maximum amount of
impact on the world that I know I could
have and in fact because I was kind of
neurotic I also had this like formula in
my head I was like I will maximize for
like the greatest delta per patient
across the creative number of patients
in the shortest period of time so that
led me to science because you know I
thought at the time what better way to
really
impact people than to really change the
way they interact with their bodies and
the way they live their lives so
actually went to the National Institutes
of Health and had my first science
experience in high school which to be
honest I absolutely hated I was at the
bench I was pipetting I was like doing
these molecular biology experiments and
it was a very classical kind of
old-school form of molecular biology
which teaches us that one gene in your
DNA always corresponds to one protein
and there are scientists that dedicate
their entire lives to actually just
studying one gene to in hopes of finding
a link to disease but this all changed
one day when one day during lab meeting
this blood member got up and gave a lab
meeting and his name is dr. buck
DeStefano UKTI and he was this Austrian
biophysicist I was kind of like what is
a physicist doing in a cancer biology
lab but then he showed in his meeting
these beautiful Network diagrams of
hundreds of different genes and so it
turns out that the story is much more
complex it turns out there are over
twenty two thousand five hundred genes
in our genome each of which together
encode for over a hundred thousand
proteins and he asked what if instead of
studying one gene at a time we actually
looked at how all of these genes
interact to cause disease and it was
just something that was so obvious to me
I couldn't stop thinking about it the
next night I was like you know like what
can I do to get involved this makes so
much sense that we look at hundreds of
genes at a time to study a disease so
the next day I went up to his door and I
knocked on his door and I asked hey is
there how can I get involved in more
projects and in a very kind of gruff
european way he was like well why don't
you just go and code up like find all
hundred thousand proteins in the human
podium put together a map and come back
to me when you're done and oh by the way
you'll need to know python and being a
high school student I was like okay cool
yeah we'll do and I left his office I
beeline straight
for my task immediately googled what is
Python and that is legitimately how I
learn how to code which was really this
driven by this burning desire to really
understand how these biological networks
worked and unbeknownst to me this was
actually part of a larger historical
narrative that was happening at the time
easy in the 1950s we had the molecular
biology revolution which really gave us
two tools to study one gene at a time
and this enabled companies such as
Genentech biogenetic Amgen to start but
in the 2000s we had the genomics
revolution the human genome was
sequenced which gave us the tools to
study tens of thousands of genes at once
and this meant drug discovery was no
longer a biology problem but it became a
data science problem it became a physics
problem it became a problem of multiple
disciplines and I believe that the next
generation of biotech companies will
rely on integrating all of these
disciplines together to be successful
and so this is my kind of second turning
point so I'm kind of going to walk
through a series of turning points and
that I felt like set me up for starting
the company even though I didn't know at
that time and this is a really critical
one so fast forward a few years later
I'm in college and I'm studying in the
lab of Saitama Zoi who is one of the
pioneers in genomics in cancer biology
and so at the time it was the end of my
senior year in college and I was
thinking you know I think the MD ph.d
might really be the best way to tackle
that life mission of mine which was to
make as much impact as possible but I
was 20 at the time the MD ph.d program
is like eight years I've minimum up to
twelve to fifteen years and I just like
was having this existential crisis I
could not fathom what eight years meant
nor could I commit to anything I was
like do I really want to be a physician
scientist how do I even know like do I
really want to be a doctor he kind of
sat me down he and he told me like look
Alice there's
no way that you know that you will want
to become a doctor unless you just start
medical school and you won't know if you
want to be a professor unless you just
start graduate school and you know you
don't like it you know you can always
just leave or pivot you're not committed
to it for the rest of your life but at
least then you will not have left any
rock unturned and you'll just have
gotten started and so that was a really
a really big lightbulb moment for me and
I think to this day I see so many people
get stuck on these paths that they think
they've committed to and really have
their lives ruled by this kind of sunk
cost fallacy and in reality you'll never
know you'll never know whether or not a
path is right for you unless you just
take the first step unless you just get
started
and that was just really big for me
throughout the rest of my career
ironically it was also a big thing for
me when I decided to leave the md/phd so
this is in 2010 when I began my MD PhD
with 11 other colleagues interestingly
actually four of these people did not
end up finishing the program and I
actually met my co-founder who is that
guy right behind me on this very day
this picture was taken and so when I
started medical school in a lot of ways
it was profoundly fulfilling you know I
got to see these patients every day it
felt like I was making an impact on
individual patients and their families
but I couldn't keep this kind of gnawing
feeling I was having but you know that
was it you know I could see patients and
it would be impactful for them
but there was a limit to how many
patients I could see in my lifetime and
so I transitioned to the PhD and that's
when I started focusing on drug
discovery for my thesis and specifically
on the very earliest stages of drug
discovery so right now in even the first
phase of drug discovery it takes about
five years and over quarter billion
dollars to even just screen through
drugs and find drugs that work and this
is because a lot of pharma companies are
paying for failures
oftentimes their brute-force screening
tens to hundreds of thousands of
compounds just to identify one that
works in the lab and I thought there
must be a better way to do this and so
back in grad school I started coding up
some of the first algorithms to find it
new drugs for nerve regeneration so
spinal cord injury nerve injury and
quite shockingly the very first drug
that was predicted by the algorithm when
we put it into mice with crush nerves
helped them recover function of their
nerves much faster than even the leading
standard and this list just the first
drug retested and so when compared to
the current Pharma success rate I
thought wow this is really a compelling
finding but when I was writing it up for
publication just writing up the
manuscript and kind of thought like do I
want to just publish this and let it sit
on a bookshelf somewhere or what is the
best path text should get getting this
product to patients and I realized that
really if I wasn't going to be the one
to push it out there be very few other
people that would be as qualified to
really advance this to commercialization
and I think the second thing that was
happening for me at the time was I went
into this PhD with really big hopes that
I could make a discovery that would
impact billions but what I realized was
the kind of realities of day-to-day
academia were very much still focused on
publications first and not so much on
direct patient translation so in many
ways it's ironic because the actual
reason it went into the MD ph.d ended up
also being also the reason I left which
was I found that starting a startup was
the most direct fulfillment of creating
patient impact as quickly as possible
this is also another reason I ended up
leaving my program which was we got into
Y Combinator and so I she learned about
Y Combinator through two Google searches
and their first was what is an incubator
and then the second one was what is the
best incubator in the world this was
first links I clicked on it and I
realized that the applications are due
in about a week so my co-founder and I
went anyway like spent a week writing up
this application and the day before it
was due I gave it to a friend that's has
started a startup and he just tells me
Alice we're gonna need to forget
everything they taught you grad school
and write this like you would write it
for your mom so your mom could
understand and that was another light
bulb moment for me which was like
they've taught me all in a specific way
to write in the specific jargon in grad
school I had to unlearn but that was
also a huge lesson for me in just
entrepreneurship which is the first step
is actually learning how to communicate
your idea in a way that's as simple as
possible and figure out what people
you're talking to care about and
communicate it to why they should
actually care about your idea
so actually ended up scrapping in
pulling an all-nighter rewriting it
actually thinking that my mom was gonna
read it and we got in and so I kinda
wanna end with an at least this section
there's a lot of people ask me and they
say oh you must have been so brave to
leave the grad school program or to make
the leap but the honest answer is it
never felt like a leap it always felt
like a next step and it felt like the
next step towards answering just a long
list of questions and I felt feel like
that's a lot of what entrepreneurship is
so the first question for us was will
anyone even care about this idea and
luckily we found that YC did care and
then the next question was can we
actually get funding to grow our idea
and the question after that was can we
build an initial team to actually build
the product and can we actually grow a
team to take the product to the next
level so really this was just a give a
cascading journey of individual steps
but it really taught me that the most
important thing is to just stay
adaptable and I think that people gets
so caught up and trying to figure out
like where do I want to end up what is
the best path there is the
really where I want to be when in
reality you can never really know and
the best thing you can do is just to
take the next step to find out more
information if that is true or not so
I'm going to talk a little bit about
some of the challenges that I face
specifically when building an AI and
drug discovery company and so when I
first started I realized that one of the
biggest barriers right now from
preventing AI from fully realizing it's
potential and drug discovery are these
huge silos that exists between different
industries that there's silos that exist
between computational teams biology
chemistry drug development and even
academia and industry and the first
thing I wanted to do was to create a
team that broke down some of these silos
so we really set out from day one to
create this truly integrated team that
combines top experts in machine learning
and statistics with drug developers
neurobiologists and chemists and it's
been so important to have these people
sitting side by side with each other
because the computational people really
understand what they're making they
really understand what their product
needs to look like and the biologists
can design experiments that produce the
right types of data for the
computational team I think another
challenge that we face when we first
started was a lot of companies have
trouble figuring out how they actually
create value from their algorithms and
so we decided from day one that we
didn't want to just be a software
company but we actually wanted to own
the products or the potential
billion-dollar drugs that would come out
of our platform so what we did from day
one was create a vertically integrated
company what that means is that we have
both the front end of our machine
learning algorithms as well as the our
own in-house drug discovery and animal
facilities and labs so this allows us
to actually create our own sets of
proprietary data by sourcing thousands
of different patient brains and
sequencing it ourselves and mining this
data to figure out what are the groups
of genes or gene networks that are
causing disease by looking at these gene
networks we've been able to build a
robust first in class drug portfolio of
over a dozen breakthrough opportunities
in six different diseases and
importantly because we have our own
integrated labs we can quickly turn
these predictions into real drugs as
well as sieve our predictions actually
work and feed that data back in to
continuously improve the algorithms so
if the second challenge I see facing the
field is really a problem of data
availability so machine learning and PAC
is fundamentally different from machine
learning in biology because most of
human biology is still unknown that's to
say there's a huge missing data problem
and we encountered this problem when we
actually were looking at the datasets
available and we saw that these datasets
were vastly underpowered and poorly
designed and could not be used for
machine learning and what's important
here is that the sophistication of your
algorithms is irrelevant if you don't
have enough data from which to train and
to learn so we've embarked on this
two-year internal data generation
initiative where we now generate all of
our own proprietary patient data sets
and we do this by partnering with over a
dozen different hospitals rain banks and
universities to actually source
thousands of patient brains after
they've died and we sequence that
internally to create now one of the
largest patient training data sets in
the world for ALS and Parkinson's
disease but while training data is
really important for generating
predictions for every AI company you
need to have validation data
so we take all of these predictions and
we actually test them in our biology
labs to create a huge body of validation
data that feeds back into the algorithms
and constantly improves them over time
and across diseases as well and this is
critical for any company in AI and
biology because AI cannot be a black box
in biology you need to have a way to
actually see if the predictions work and
to let those predictions guide the
improvement of the actual algorithms
themselves and so the last challenge we
have sounds pretty simple does it even
work so there's this concept in startups
that there are two types of risk there's
technical risks can you build a product
and market risk do people want your
product and so for biotech companies the
market risk is pretty obvious if you
created an Alzheimer's disease tomorrow
that actually worked you'd immediately
have hundreds of millions of people
clamoring to get that drug and willing
to pay anything so the biggest challenge
really is technical risk and that's huge
does what you're predicting actually
work and will it work in a patient and
that's the biggest challenge and that's
another reason why we built out this
vertical integration because if you
don't have labs you can't test if your
predictions are working but you can't
just go into a human from day one to
test it and a big challenge in drug
discovery that's led to a lot of
failures are that people only test in
mice before they go into humans and mice
drugs and mice historically haven't
translated well in neuroscience so what
we've done instead Everage is we've
leveraged a new technology using human
stem cells and what we can do is we can
actually take skin cells from patients
with disease such as Alzheimer's disease
and we can actually turn those into
brain cells in a dish and then we
combine that with robotic systems
internally to be able to test all of our
API predictions at scale and cheap and
automated human trials before we even go
to clinic
so here's one of the systems that we use
to test our predictions we plate the
patient brain cells on this dish and we
treat them with the drugs predicted by
our platform this robotic arm then comes
along every day takes a plate up from
the incubator and places said underneath
the microscope at the same exact
location this microscope then moves
along and images each well up to
multiple times a day enabling us to
recreate the live growth and
degeneration of individual living brain
cells in real patients with ALS
Parkinson's disease in Alzheimer's
disease so this is a live type this is a
time-lapse image from a real brain cells
from a real patient with ALS and you can
see here that over time they these white
lines disintegrate into these tiny white
dots and that's the process of the cell
dying this is also the same process that
causes ALS in patients now we can
actually take these images and we can
algorithmically analyze them and create
these types of survival curves so on the
x-axis you have time over the course of
days and the y axis you have percent of
the cells that are still living and you
can see on the red line that als patient
brain cells tend to die off much more
quickly than on the black line which are
healthy patient brain cells now what's
been so exciting for us over the last
year is that when we took the first drug
from our platform and we put it into
these very same ALS patients brain cells
we could actually completely rescue them
from dying in fact restoring them to the
very same levels as healthy patients
this is the first time that any a I
predicted drug has worked not only in
mice but also in human brain cells as
well so I kind of just want to end with
you know where do I think biotech is
going over the the next five to ten
years
and really starting with an area that's
near and dear to my heart
neurodegeneration so I talked about some
of the challenges with drug discovery
and in no other disease is it as severe
as in neuro degeneration so Alzheimer's
disease currently is hutt is the only
disease that has actual growing death
rates and it's the only disease of top
diseases in which there's no drugs that
can slow prevent or cure these diseases
and as we all get older we'll be
increasingly affected by these diseases
so why can't we figure it it out it's
because these diseases are incredibly
complex and the traditional drug
discovery method isn't sufficient to
tackle them in fact in the last year
there have been seven billion-dollar
Alzheimer's failures from Big Pharma and
in fact last year Pfizer announced that
it was shuttering its entire
neuroscience division laying off over
300 employees but what is less written
about is the scientific and
technological Renaissance that's
actually happening in neuroscience right
now and I think it's super interesting
because any time you have a big
incumbent that is turning away from a
huge untapped market combined with a
convergence of technological advances
you create this sort of Moneyball
opportunity for smaller companies to
really come along and transform the
entire landscape and I'll talk about a
couple of these advances the first of
course is genomics so in 2000 some of
you might have seen this figure in mm it
cost over a hundred million dollars to
sequence a single genome today it cost
less than a thousand dollars and in fact
this has dropped so quickly that it's
even surpassed what's predicted by
Moore's law of computing costs and so
just like the decline in computing cost
has fundamentally changed the way we
interact with the physical world I think
that this Inc
and genomic data will change the way we
think about disease now I'm going to
talk about three additional technologies
that we use our urge to get a leg up on
drug discovery the first is that we are
one of the first to actually be able to
collect brain samples and sequence them
from live patients with Parkinson's
disease so this is deep brain
stimulation it's an advanced in surgery
that allows us to implant a device into
a patient's brain and turn it on to
prevent Parkinson's patients from having
tremors but there's also a second
unexpected advantage here which is that
we can actually access patient tissue
from a patient while he or she is still
living and sequence it to be the first
to get an unprecedented glimpse into
earlier disease progression we've also
started single cell sequencing which is
the technology I think will
revolutionize genomics in the next five
years so instead of sequencing patient
brains at the tissue level we can
actually take individual cells and
sequence their nuclei in that for the
first time because it's a glimpse into
sol-type complexity at a resolution we
haven't been able to achieve before and
lastly using the same technology I
showed you earlier in our lab we're now
also able to take patients skin cells
and actually turn them into 3d brain
organoids in the lab which allow us to
model the brain in an area a degree of
complexity we haven't seen before so a
lot of these technologies like these I
will also change the type of companies
that are coming out and I think these
advances have already led to a
proliferation of biotech companies with
non-traditional profiles so these are
companies that have been started by
technologists and biologists coming
together and are led by savvy teams that
grew up in the genomics of the AI era
and these are teams are recognizing the
importance of creating multidisciplinary
teams that interface between computer
science
and computational biology and I think
there will be an explosion of these
types of companies in the next five
years so I want to end with you know
while we're while I consider us in this
kind of new era of biotech companies
life sciences is still a very
traditional field for example it's very
rare for there to be a founder who is
also a CEO today in biotech and most are
really started by a small group of
venture capital firms that bring in
professional management so in the very
beginning it was quite challenging for a
company like ours to really break
through and I learned a couple really
important lessons and how he can
actually create an advantage from
scratch and the first thing I learned
was do things that are laborious
especially in the beginning because as a
founder you will need to be the one
doing things yourself to really
kickstart the company as an example when
I first started the company to hire the
team I we our initial team
I personally interviewed about a
thousand 200 people myself and I did
that by actually going on upwork.com
finding some out sourced
people on on up work and actually then
going through a decade's worth of
publications from nature cell science
whatever had the word genomics in it I
found the first three authors found
their emails and I would email out
hundreds of people per week I like to
think every computational biologist has
the email from me in their inbox but
that was really really really critical
for me
because not only did I understand and
learn the field understand how to hire
but I was able to recruit a rock star
team exactly in the mold of what I
envisioned for the team and it was after
building that really stellar team that
made recruiting actually so much easier
after that the next lesson is when I
take consider really important for
myself personally which is that I think
it's one of my greatest responsibilities
as a CEO to
faster personally than your company does
so what do I mean that by that the first
thing is that you have to get really
comfortable with taking a hard look at
yourself and understanding what it is
you're bad at well you don't know and
what you need to learn and you to get
really ok with that and then you need to
be absolutely shameless about learning
it finding advisors filling the gaps and
so I always like to save rich was built
on a foundation of cold emails whenever
I found I didn't know anything whether
it was nice business development or a
drug development I would literally go
and put together a list of emails of who
I think is the best of the best and I
would just cold email them actually is
very surprised about how many people
responded but that's kind of how I
started building my foundation of
expertise and I think the last thing is
that you have to stay hungry to find
stepwise functions for personal growth
so rather than trying things through
trial and error how can I find things I
will really boost my own growth and so
things have worked for me for example
our executive coaching reading a ton of
books and finding other founders that
have gone through it and so that brings
me to my last point which is that you
know being a founder is a very singular
it's a very challenging and oftentimes
it's a really lonely experience and so I
would not be where I was now if I do not
myself find a group of other founders
that would eventually become my best
friends with the shared experiences so
these are people that I would literally
text on midnight and feel like crap I
have to fire someone for the first time
how do I fire someone and then I would
text someone like I just fired someone
does anyone want to grab a drink these
are people that really have seen we've
seen each other's companies really from
beginning all the way through our
friends company was just acquired last
week so that's a picture taken last week
and I think this is so important because
as a founder it's really really hard to
know where to get good advice you're
going to be told with
do by your investors but your advisors
by your employees none of which are sure
has the company's best interest heart
and so I think the best advice I've
always gotten have been from other
founders that have gone through the same
thing especially founders that are about
a year or two ahead of me and that's
really the best way to kind of
anticipate what you don't know and
lastly I feel like building a important
building a personal support network for
yourself is really key to actually
building a sustainable business across
time because you will need places to
look for advice throughout the whole
entire journey
so I'll started taking questions now
[Applause]